the late great dmx you know it's been a
little over a week since the rapper
who's given name
is earl simmons was laid to rest now in
this exclusive new interview we hear x
in his own words for the final time
i always feel like i'm gonna look back
on my life just before i go and uh
thank god for every moment the rapper's
final interview was filmed in march just
three weeks before the 50 year old died
after suffering a heart attack
up until i was 20 you know i was told i
wouldn't live to see 20. oh you said i
was gonna live okay
now i fight harder to live
[Music]
ex in his own words shares personal
stories even
opening up about forgiving his mother
for an abusive childhood
and she walked yeah she walked in the
door
i think it's at that point right there
that i just let everything go
part one of the two-hour special
uncensored dmx airs sunday may 16 on tv
one
ahead of the urban one honors part two
will air the following night
give me a second every good idea it's a
gift from god
and how you say thank you is by using it
[Applause]
by the way you will hear from his mom
and ex-wife in part
two of that special